Apple's iPhone 15 Pro and Ultra are
about to get the biggest advantage that
they've had in years compared to their
Android competitors and this is crazy
because we just got a report saying that
apple is likely to be the only major
device maker with three nanometer chips
in 2023 as Qualcomm is reportedly caught
in a dilemma so in this video I'm going
to explain exactly what that means what
the Dilemma is and why apple is going to
be in such a good position this year now
the Dilemma from Qualcomm and mediatek
is that they are unclear on whether the
newer process is worth it and that's a
new report from digitimes saying that
they have not made a clear decision just
yet to join the three nanometer camp
this year despite both hoping to keep up
with Apple's process upgrade for their
flagship mobile socs and if none of this
makes sense to you and you don't know
why Qualcomm and mediatek wouldn't go
after apple as fast as possible well
there there are some downsides in the
tech industry right now for example
shipments of smartphones within China
fell 34.1 percent year over year in
November that is a huge drop so
basically less smartphone sales and of
course each of those smartphones
especially the Android ones come with
mediatek and Qualcomm chips and it's not
only the smartphone industry it's the
entire tech industry because if you look
at PC sales specifically desktop GPU
sales we just hit a 20-year low yes for
the past 20 years we have not had sales
this bad for desktop gpus and Sony just
said that their PlayStation 5 shortage
is finally over and that's because Tech
demand is going down right now even for
consoles and the last quarter before
that in the summer they said that
they're gaining profits fell 49 due to
Rising costs which is unfortunate and
part of that reason is because Americans
personal savings rate the share of
disposable income left over after
spending has hit the lowest level since
2005. so people have less extra money to
spend on Tech and everything else that
they don't necessarily need and by far
the worst news that we just got is that
Samsung's profits have plummeted 69 year
over year on falling demand for
processors 69 that is a massive drop
from last year and this is of course
impacting everybody in the chip making
business Samsung Qualcomm Media Tech
everyone so my thought after hearing
that news was what's going to happen
with Apple at this last quarter is that
why we didn't get a new Mac for the
first time in 20 years is that why we
got the M2 iPad Pro which is a
disappointing update maybe apple is also
getting hit but let's get into why Apple
actually has the biggest Advantage
starting later this year with the iPhone
15 Pro we just got a leak from shrimp
Apple Pro saying that the a17 bionic
chip that we're expecting and the iPhone
15 Pro and Ultra is going to be based on
tsmc's three nanometer process yes three
nanometer and this is not the first time
we've been hearing this because way back
in September we actually got a report
from Nicki Asia saying that the a17 ship
for the iPhone 15 Pro will use tsmc's
second generation 3 nanometer process
and guess what just happened a week ago
Apple supplier tsmc has officially
started mass production on three
nanometer chips and those are most
likely going into Apple's products maybe
even their Max but for sure the iPhone
15 Pro and Ultra models and this is
where we go back to this article saying
that apple is likely going to be the
only major device maker with three
nanometer chips this year as Qualcomm is
caught in a dilemma so let's get into
why Qualcomm specifically is in their
dilemma they just had their earnings
back in November saying that their
revenue forecast falls short as
smartphone sales slump and their shares
of their stocks slighted and that's of
course the same thing we saw with
smartphone sales going down in China and
going even further Qualcomm literally
warned of weak smartphone sales saying
that there was a rapid deterioration in
demand for semiconductors or chips and
then moving over to mediatek they also
did the same thing back in July cutting
their revenue forecasts expecting demand
for chips to dip down and then another
us-based semiconductor manufacturer spun
off from AMD Global foundries planned up
to 800 layoffs and that was announced
back in December so they are suffering
as well and it's not only them because
there's already a huge list of tech
layoffs that have been announced in just
the first few days of January as you can
see right here the tech industry is not
going well right now and here is where
we finally get into the major dilemma
digit times said that tsmc's three
nanometer wafer price breaks twenty
thousand dollars per wafer and that of
course means that we should be expecting
price increases for the iPhone 15. now
if you look at this chart you can see
that the five nanometer Wafers were
priced at around 16 000 so that means a
25 increase in cost for the three
nanometer chips compared to five
nanometers so that basically explains
the Dilemma for Qualcomm and mediatek
because if they are making chips that
are going into Android phones and those
Android phones are going down in terms
of demand and sales then why would they
decide to go up to three nanometer which
is even more expensive 25 percent more
expensive while sales are actually
slumping and going down it does not make
sense and that's why they're saying it
might not be worth it but thankfully for
Apple their iPhone sales demand has been
keeping up quite well and they actually
have a ton of cash reserves to weather
the storm even if they have to have
smaller or lower profit margins they can
get a massive Advantage this year with
the iPhone 15 Pros a17 ship being on
three nanometer while everybody else is
behind and waiting until everything
kicks back up before following in
Apple's footsteps and here's where we
get into the first major advantage it
was reported that Apple's a17 bionic
chip could be 35 more energy efficient
enabling longer battery life that is
literally a game that's going to be
happening from the newer three nanometer
chip process technology which is going
to be a huge boost and only apple is
going to be getting it this year because
everybody else is not going to be
switching to three nanometer just yet
and the crazy thing about all of that is
that the iPhone 14 pro Max with the a16
chip still on four nanometer which is
basically retuned five nanometer
rebranded it's already beating other
Flagship phones like the pixel 7 Pro and
the fold 4 in terms of speed test as you
can see it finished in two minutes and
45 seconds compared to 253 for the fold
4 and 310 for the pixel 7 Pro and these
are the flagship new chips and on top of
that in terms of the actual battery life
the iPhone 14 pro Max is already beating
the s22 ultra by a huge margin I as you
can see active standby time 11 hours and
38 minutes compared to 9 hours and 16.
it's already got the battery life down
especially considering the smaller
battery size compared to 5 000 milliamp
hours on the s22 ultra but then going
even further in terms of actual gaming
performance compared to even newer chips
like the Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 and the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 the iPhone 14 pro Max
is getting higher average FPS of 58.5
compared to 56.8 it's already beating
them out and the crazy thing about that
is that the iPhone 14 pro faced an
unprecedented setback leading to the
removal of a new graphics processor
apparently Apple had a brand new design
for their GPU that was meant to go into
the a16 bionic chip but it got canceled
because of power usage so they basically
just reverted back to the same a15 GPU
that they had our ready and kind of
adjusted the clock speed so if you
imagine that the a17 bionic chip is
going to be on three nanometer but it's
also going to have a brand new GPU
design that's more energy efficient
especially if they have more time to fix
those power issues that they had and of
course the three nanometer is going to
help
Apple was already ahead of everybody
else now they're going to be even more
ahead in terms of performance and
battery life basically boosting them up
massively compared to the competition
and not only that but we of course are
expecting a brand new full redesign for
the iPhone 15 lineup including Titanium
on the iPhone 15 Pro and Ultra frame
taptic buttons increased RAM and of
course a brand new design with a
periscope camera as you can see in these
renders that I created with renders by
Shailesh so the idea is Apple's iPhone
15 Pro is going to be better than you
think and the chip itself the a17 is
going to have a huge Advantage compared
to all of the other smartphones
especially the s23 ultra which is coming
up soon still on the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
which the a16 already beats so so that
is crazy and I think Apple's gonna have
a huge advantage next year compared to
everybody else that is suffering from
these demand issues I think Apple's
gonna do just fine compared to them so
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you agree on what I'm saying you can
leave a comment down below or you can
disagree if you want if you want to see
which iPhone I would recommend to buy
right now you can check it out using the
YouTube product tagging feature below
and click the circle above for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign